à la barre la directrice du centre n'a
pu réprimer ses larmes quand la
présidente du tribunal a dressé le
portrait de la jeune aurélie à 16 ans
sont apprentis venus faire un ca paix
dans son centre équestre
aurélia une jeune fille passionnée de
chevaux qui a mis fin à ses jours en
août 2016 un acte dramatique qui selon
sa mère serait dû à un contexte de
harcèlement moral
alors c'est vrai la gérante en
difficulté économique ne paient pas
toujours à temps les salaires à la buse
est souvent sur les horaires et puis
n'at-elle pas déjà été condamné pour
maltraitance sur animaux une peine de
six mois de prison avec sursis mais cela
constitue-t-il le harcèlement moral et s
la véritable cause du suicide
après quatre heures de débats l'avocat
général a demandé la relaxe pour la
gérante
car entre temps le parcours de vie très
difficiles très chaotique d'aurélia a
été mise en lumière
et puis dans sa lettre d'adieu elle ne
parle à aucun moment du centre et de sa
patronne mais bien d'une rupture
sentimentale avec son petit ami
on a pu en arriver là parce qu'il y ait
eu une rupture sentimentale pour cette
jeune fille qu'il y avait eu un climat
familial délétère chaotique de la
violence intrafamiliale une jeune fille
qui était quand même suivi par un juge
des enfants qui étaient en souffrance à
bien des égards et pour d'autres motifs
que des motifs professionnels
ni la famille d'aurélia ses parents ses
soeurs ni même leurs avocats n'étaient
présents aujourd'hui au tribunal comme
si aucun d'entre eux ne soutenait
vraiment l'accusation qu'ils avaient
porté le tribunal a mis son jugement en
délibéré le 4 juillet prochain